madame Olivier bonsoir bonsoir donc vous
première réaction hier quand j'ai vu ça
sur les logements sociaux-étiens très
déçus effectivement parce que cette
année nous on avait fait madame plante
et moi un exercice de rigueur quand on a
parlé au ministre on lui a dit on
comprend la difficulté qui a à faire le
budget dans le contexte actuel alors on
a décidé de faire deux demandes la
première c'était sur le logement c'était
sur le logement social et abordable et
la seconde sur le financement du
transport en commun et pour nous c'était
clair on était prêt à prendre je vous
dirais la chaleur on devrait apprendre
le risque qu'on nous transfère les
unités qui sont en attente d'être
construites dans excelus Québec et qu'on
les amène dans accès logement Réal donc
nous la Ville de Montréal on s'assure
qu'elle soit construite mais ceci ça
coûtait à peu près 315 millions pour
pouvoir faire
1800 presque 1900 logements mais qui ont
déjà été premier que les gens attendent
d'avoir et quand j'ai entendu les
chiffres du ministre je me suis dit ah
bah clairement on n'a pas été bien
comprise ok mais là on va essayer de se
démêler d'abord on va écouter monsieur
Legros ce matin qui vous envoie un
message qui dit oui mais l'argent est
pas dépensé que j'ai déjà donné alors il
faut que vous trouviez des terrains et
de la main d'oeuvre on écoute pour faire
le défi c'est vraiment
d'accélérer la construction de logements
et quand on passe par l'OMH ça prend
quatre ans construire que donc quand
même qu'on ajouterait puis qu'on
ajouterait de l'argent il y avait déjà
avant le budget de l'argent pas dépenser
c'est spécial donc il faut trouver le
moyen
d'accélérer la délivrance de permis la
recherche de terrain etc etc
donc il s'adresse à la ville puis dit
accélérer les choses puis vous aurez
plus d'argent qu'est-ce que vous
répondez que nous on a pris nos
responsabilités les choses sont déjà
accélérées on a investi 120 millions de
dollars pour trouver des terrains qui
existent qu'on a à l'autre qui sont à
notre possession on a réussi à faire une
cellule facilitatrice pour accélérer la
délivrance permis temps privée qu'au
communautaire mais le problème qu'on a
c'est que on calcule le coût des unités
sur le prix de 2009 il y a eu aucune
indexation depuis 2009 essayez de
construire en 2023 avec l'inflation avec
le poste pandémique avec la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre avec la hausse des coups
de construction essayer de construire
parce que ça coûtait il y a 15 ans on va
démêler les chiffres mais juste pourquoi
monsieur Legault peut dire qu'il y a de
l'argent qui dort parce que chaque année
le gouvernement comme je vous dis à une
année de référence qui est il y a
presque 15 ans maintenant sur le
de construction donc quand tu donnes de
l'argent il donne de l'argent basé sur
cette équivalent
de coups des autres des logements et
maintenant on se retrouve avec une
inflation des coûts jamais assez
d'argent pour que les plages au bout
c'est une vraie classique c'est une
partie de l'argent à temps mais si on
n'a pas le vrai argent des vrais coups
de construction ils arriveront jamais à
aller à les faire chaque année ça coûte
plus cher je veux réconcilier mais là je
pense je comprends vous dites il a
raison de dire qu'il y a de l'argent qui
attend puis vous dire oui il y a de
l'argent qui attend mais on a besoin du
reste pour pouvoir dans les faits faire
construire les logements exactement
depuis la promesse de monsieur Legault
de 2018 là il y avait promis 14000
logements eux disent qu'il y en a 9000
soit construits ou en voie de lettres
bon il y en a à Montréal là-dedans et
eux disent que dans le budget d'hier sur
les cinq prochaines années à 5200 quand
je vous dis c'est pas si mal qu'est-ce
qu'on comprend non d'abord d'abord il y
a une chose que je veux qu'on comprenne
j'ai entendu monsieur le groupe parler
du temps mais j'aurais envie de lui dire
comme le logement social répond
exactement à la même logique que les
marchés publics ça prend pas plus de
temps que ça prend de construire des
écoles construire des hôpitaux et c'est
exactement le même phénomène de hausse
de coût auquel on assiste donc ça
mettons ça de côté au point de départ
ensuite ce que je dis c'est nous on a
évalué les coûts réels de construction
des quelques 1800 logements qui sont en
attente à 314 millions si on prend la
part de Montréal ça c'est les 1800 qui
font partie de la promesse de 2018 qu'on
a déjà annoncé puis qui aurait dû être
déjà construits qui ne sont pas encore
construits 350 il nous manquait 314
millions on en a eu 88 après 80 donc non
seulement vous dites qu'on pourra pas
s'engager dans un nouveau programme on
arrivera même pas avec ce que vous avez
là à construire ce qui était première
2018 le camp de l'argent donne le quart
des résultats il y a pas de formule
magique puis combien de gens sont en
attente à Montréal 24
000 ménages sont présentés en attente
d'un logement et ça quand on regarde les
nouveaux logements qui sont annoncés
également on a le même problème parce
que un certain nombre d'unités qui va
venir à Montréal à mon avis c'est autour
de 600
aucun sens dans le budget d'hier les
sommes parce que on annonce quand même
1500 pour cette année pour le Québec il
y a quand même l'argent nouveau vous
dites pour à peu près 600 unités on
pense où l'équivalent de 600 logements
ok donc ça s'ajoute quand même qui va
venir s'ajouter mais il va quand même
manquer 314 millions ce que vous dites
pour financer ce qui était déjà premier
exactement
le vrai coup et on finance pas à la
hauteur des besoins donc qu'est-ce qui
arrive à partir une campagne la mairesse
de Hauteville vous dites il nie la crise
du logement jusqu'où vous allez pour
nous c'est clair que il y a eu un choix
politique qui a été fait hier et je vais
pas comprendre qu'on le juge moi je
pense que c'est au gouvernement de juger
de faire ses choix on a choisi de
baisser les impôts avec les 9 milliards
que cotent les baisses d'impôts on
aurait pu régler ce problème là il y a
un choix qui est fait de ne pas le
régler alors maintenant il faut que le
gouvernement nous explique pourquoi et
quand couler soi ailleurs vous demander
une partie du 300 millions des
l'augmentation des coûts par rapport à
ce qui avait été donné on vous dit quoi
ben pour nous on nous dit il faut
construire ce qui est déjà sorti ce qui
est déjà sur terre mais en même temps il
y a des années où ils n'ont pas du tout
contribué au logement social il y a eu
deux ans 2020-2021 zéro contribution
donc on se dit on creuse les câbles donc
tant qu'on creuse des cas il va falloir
faire des choix bon là il reste une
minute vous avez votre responsabilité la
ville de aussi pour mieux inspecter des
logements et salubre pour en faire
davantage dans le logement là vous avez
une part de responsabilité aussi
absolument
et nous on n'hésite pas à se retrousser
les manches depuis 2018 l'administration
plante a fait de l'habitation son cheval
de bataille c'est le lait qu'on veut
laisser au montréalé c'est un toit sur
la tête ça va régler en même temps
certains problèmes itinérances certains
problèmes d'abus les inégalités sociales
par extension ailleurs même dans
l'incendie malheureusement manque
d'inspection manque de nous ce qu'on
fait par rapport à ça c'est qu'on a créé
on est en train de créer la
certification de propriétaire
responsable on dit au lieu d'attendre
les plaintes on va donner l'obligation
propriétaire de sylogements et plus de
nous montrer que leur bâtiment sont en
état est-ce qu'on aura une alliance des
grandes municipalités pour continuer ce
combat-là du logement abordable je pense
que même au-delà des grandes
municipalités même les petites
municipalités tout le monde vit au
Québec la crise logement il manque
50000 logements au Québec à l'échelle du
Québec au moment où on se parle 50 000
logements Dominique Olivier merci
beaucoup président du comité exécutif
vous avez de Montréal merci de nous
avoir rendu visite merci de m'avoir
invité